artificial
general intelligence
artificial general intelligence
a g i we
are starting to get deeper
and deeper tastes of what it feels like
to be building technology
that is superior to
humanity and it's beautiful and it's
important
similar with the advancement from chimps
to humans
now is the advancement from humans to
artificial
general intelligence to superhuman if
you will
and we must become
simultaneously
intelligent around the design of this
and the architecture of it
and enabling it to completely
be uplifting all people
around the world at the same time
as we must in a sense
surrender also to the fact that this is
evolution
this is the telos this is the trajectory
and the direction that we are heading
now i want us to talk a little bit about
what it means to be building a pattern
recognition
god and as you can tell
from your own experience as humans
your ability to recognize where patterns
are is in the in essence
what you are and who you are and you
have a hierarchical
inference about the world around you
so you know certain things that you're
going to do
are going to lead to more efficacious
outcomes
you don't you don't take a banana and
you don't take that banana
and not peel it before eating it you
you know the pattern is to peel it first
right when you when you go to the
bathroom you know the order of
operations
in terms of using the bathroom flushing
washing your hands drying them off
etc so you know the proper pattern so
similar with an artificial general
intelligence
is that when it takes in an input like a
command
around making an application or making
some sort of a design or writing some
sort of
text or helping out with the query that
you send it of any sort
the same style of process occurs where
the idea
is that the more that it takes in the
input
and provides an output that is
approximately
what is needed by the user that was
putting in the input
the more gets rewarded and the more it
understands that that style
of learning is exactly an output is
exactly what is being
asked of it and that's why it's trained
on this massive
corpus of hundreds of thousands and more
of different um
websites and books and i mean we're
talking
billions this time we're talking 500
billion
pieces of training material we're
talking 175 billion parameters which is
crazy gbt2
is only 1.5 billion parameters
so this is a significant increase in
terms of the technological capabilities
and also the generality of it the
generality of it is insane because if
you do something like take
someone that is like a developer or a
designer right now i'm spending a lot of
my time designing this project
when i want to make a bell curve or when
i want to make a power law distribution
or when i want to make a tree
or a human or whatever i want to make
every time i make it because i'm not
borrowing from people
already online i'm just designing it by
hand myself
that i'm watching the agi currently when
you put in an input you know design
a bell curve that's the color green
or whatever you want you'll literally
just process that
and spit you out a green bell curve and
i think that that's
very important to recognize that
the amount of time that we spend and
this is a lot
based on you know the future of work is
that kids
in the future as well as adults will be
spending a lot of their time in
augmented reality ar environments
and in those ar environments there's
going to be these very simple
natural language
understanding from artificial general
intelligence and also their
generation so there's going to be a
generative right a generative
learning function a generative output
function that happens where you just
speak what you want
and you get what you want in return
and that it's super fluid with
your work space so when i want
a when i want to add a little pair of
headphones
on top of the human's ears inside of the
inside of the design that i'm making all
i do is say add a pair of headphones
to the human and boom just like that the
ai will generate
a pair of headphones on top of the
human's ears
and so you you know
change the color of the headphones to
pink
done and so that's the idea is that it's
that much more simple to be a designer
to be an
engineer to submit a query into the
internet of knowledge
the fact that right now when i want to
submit
a complicated query into the internet
and it takes me a significant amount of
time for me to parse i have to look at
like 10 different sources
i have to look at those 10 sources i
have to scrape the internet for the data
it's a complicated question sometimes
it's not that easy to figure out that
there's nitrogen and potassium
and um phosphorus that is absorbed
from the roots of the of the tree from
through the soil and the water
and so it's not easy to find that data
maybe it's not so easy to find the
the total red blood cell count that
exists
inside of the body that number is 25
trillion red blood cells but then you
want to know more about those red blood
cells
and maybe you can ask your artificial
intelligence to play you a
four minute four or five minute video on
red blood cells
and boom just like that in your
augmented reality space
you have a little four or five minute
video on red blood cells that you're
being taught
right there and so it's really it's all
about parsing the natural language of
humans
and having this massive corpus of data
right that's the idea of the general
style intelligence is that it has so
much
patterns and data it's become a pattern
god that it can take any input whether
it be to
engineer something via code and spit out
some react code
or whether that be to design you
something for your augmented reality
space or to answer a complicated query
that you have about the general corpus
that's available on the internet
so it's really super duper
fascinating to begin to kind of taste
what is the beginnings of the general
intelligence and this is a very
important moment
the more that you understand the
synthesis of science
business spirituality the more you
understand these things harmonizing and
coming together
that you can't just have one it's a it's
a three-legged bar stool
right you can't just be fluent in
science and have
absolutely no idea about what's going on
in ethics philosophies moralities
metaphysics etc you can't you can't
not know that you have the kingdom of
god within you and it's similarly true
about business if you've never
operated a business you'll never
actually understand about what it
actually takes to galvanize the teams
and the resources to be able to achieve
such great feats like what openai
achieved with this
and you know last year they got their
their partnership with microsoft a
billion dollar funding from that as well
so it's very interesting how these
things are converging and you know
google and
amazon and facebook are spending a lot
of time as well trying to make these
more general artificial intelligences so
that their users can more
simply and natively engage via just
language
into what they're trying to query
and gain data of right so another way to
think about this is that
an artificial general intelligence is
task agnostic right so it's like a
polymath
in that sense and so it has so many
complex diverse patterns that it makes
it
really easy for it to be able to take
something like okay i've input
literally you know how when you're
writing something in email or in text
and
and there's the prediction that comes up
and it's like you know are you trying to
uh fill you know you write gov gov and
then it's like
do you want to write government you know
or governance
right and so you just click which one
you want and so
it's very similar in the sense of when
you fill out when you're beginning to
fill out
data or fill out you know tables or make
designs of any sort
like just literally the finishing of
what you've started based on
intent is so interesting it's so
beautiful and it's so much more
efficient for humans
that all i have to do is do something as
simple as
the beginnings of filling in specific
data
let's say that all i'm all i'm doing is
i'm listing
um the countries of the world based on
their
their gdp the gross domestic product and
so i'm filling out the table
the united states china etc japan
germany blah blah and so as i'm as i'm
filling that
that in all of a sudden it just it caps
the fact that that's the pattern that
you're
that that that the human is intending
and boom just like that it fills in the
rest of it
along with the gdp amounts along with
maybe the gini coefficients for
inequality
along with maybe the most popular import
right if i can just
vocally say add a column most
popular import add column
most popular export
just like that you can have your country
the gdp the gini coefficient the
most popular import the most popular
export and
it's it's it's that much more creatively
do you know how long
it would take a human to go for
200 countries and go and try and find
the most
popular import or export from those
countries
it's insane how much time that would
take a human to do
and how much time it would take in
artificial general intelligence to
scrape the corpus
of collective knowledge and be able to
fill in that data and then for
for us to be able to be able to have
a a more deeper creative ability
because we no longer rely so much on the
grunt work
right this is a central pillar of the
thesis
of our project as well as you have to
imagine that there
is a chunk of of of the total job space
that lies
right in the crosshairs of software and
automation
these are highly repetitive and these
are
and these are uh this is low
amounts of computation low amounts of
cognition low amounts of creativity
so the the less computation creativity
and cognition and the more
repetition of the same thing that's
right there in the crosshairs of this
area
what is not right now in the crosshairs
of this area is things like the
the rube goldberg machine things like
that you have to find
things that artificial general
intelligence cannot yet
do things that are extremely hyper
creative it patterns that the agi
gods have not yet uncovered is a key
there
the more that you find patterns that the
agi
gods have not yet found the more
relevant you will be for the longer
amount of time
remember that that's a crucial part of
this video
find patterns that the agi gods have not
found yet and then be able to compress
those via stories
and via designs and via applications and
via companies and via music
and via film out into the world to bring
the world
value right so this is what will
keep you more relevant for longer
periods of time
as we go into the artificial general
intelligence age
and you have to remember that the idea
of having minimal
tuning as well is very important here
and a good way to analogize that is that
it's a really strong tennis player
the idea is that even if somebody
mumbles
something to you that it that doesn't
really make too much sense
you may have still captured the key
point
of it so you don't need to ask them a
question back
in order to gain what they were asking
but you just hit the ball back you're a
really good tennis player
another way to think about that is when
somebody maybe
says something to you that's an extended
amount of of
of speaking and then what you did is you
parsed to find the key point of what
they said
right maybe they were talking about
their life in in london that they spent
you know two decades living in london
and that they got married there they had
some kids there they had this job
and then what you did is you parsed out
what the most profound thing was that
they lived there
they had the kids they had the job etc
and then you hit a question
you hit a idea back you don't need
further
tune you don't need to continue in a
sense probing to figure things
out but you've already generally got
what their query is
and now you can say that hey have you
considered checking out singapore
because singapore has what you were
doing in business
singapore is doing extremely well there
in that specific regard you can you can
achieve your goals
more effectively there so to be able to
have task
agnosticism as well as minimal tuning is
going to be extremely important nobody
wants to
say you know that feeling when you say
something to an artificial intelligence
today when you're in a chat bot or
whatever and they reply something like
i don't understand or could you say that
a different way
you know every human is like [ __ ] i
don't feel like i was registered
and so that's what you don't want you
want humans to
always feel like they are being
registered that they are always
being understood and the more that
artificial general intelligence can be
able to
understand exactly what you want across
different disciplines that
is the that's the ultimate of where of
where we are heading
again it's it's it's so simple just take
yourself into any of these environments
where all you're doing is you are
in your workspace you're getting your
[ __ ] done imagine it's even further into
the future
we have a deeper amount of artificial
general intelligences
that also have augmented reality
workspaces
and it's as simple as you're doing your
work and again
instead of you having to design the
actual
airplane right you're you don't have to
actually draw and design an
airplane all you do is say you know
design an airplane and then boom it pops
up on the screen
change the color to blue boom it changes
the color to blue
fill out the rest of this table based on
the
amount of of deforestation happening
across the planet based on geographical
area and based on year
boom
program me an application that
uh stores the the cultural zeitgeist
of the most common hashtag
used per hour on twitter
per geographical area based on country
right that's a [ __ ] complicated
command for an artificial general
intelligence to do that is not
easy it's not easy especially for a
human a human would have to go and look
at every single country
and what's trending on twitter and store
every single
hour the hashtags that's trending that's
a lot of work for a human but an
artificial general intelligence can do
that much
easier and so the fact that
we can now make queries for artificial
general intelligence to do through just
our voice through just natural language
and to get back these almost
instantaneous
outputs that are task agnostic based on
this god-like 175 billion parameters
is mind-blowingly creatively unleashing
for everyone across the planet
but that's another key is that there's
there's couple keys here first of all
we need a significant amount more
resources
to train the amounts of data that are
needed there's significantly more you
can have
trillions and quadrillions of these
parameters
that you have stored but we're limited
based on the
co existing computational capacity and
the exist existing amounts of money that
it costs cost billions of dollars to
train these massive artificial general
intelligences
as computational costs decrease over
time
ill cost less and less money to be able
to train bigger and bigger
label data sets and that will be
extremely important
but what else is extremely important is
that the democratization of these
benefits
right so for example i can't get gpt 3
right now
and many of you guys can't either only a
few select people can
now what's gonna happen beyond the few
select people getting access to it okay
well we have to be careful because we
don't want to release it's just the same
thing that happened with gpt2
they want to be careful they don't want
to release gpt3 to somebody that's going
to write
terrorism propaganda articles we talked
about this a lot in our last video but
the more spiritually enlightened we
become as a civilization
the less we have to worry about people
creating malevolences with general
intelligences or biotechnologies or
neurotechnologies
etc so remember that first priority is
spiritual awakening therefore there is
no violence there is no tyranny there is
only enlightened civilization
but at the same time the idea is that
there
as we have not gotten to that state yet
it's important to understand
how to properly access this how to
properly distribute this
and how to enable people around the
world to use it one of the last things
you want is
that you want all of these major
corporations
and major one percenters across the
world being able to
further use artificial general
is to build up their creative capacities
faster than people like
us that still don't have access to these
tools or even more so people that don't
have access to clean drinking water yet
or don't have access to their other
basic needs across the planet so the
idea
is that we really need to simultaneously
funnel like biomimicry with inclusive
stakeholding which you talked about a
lot in the last video the basic needs of
people around the planet for their
creative
combinatorial gifts to be unleashed
across the world
but also that the democratization of
these benefits needs to be done
right open ai talks about this a lot and
we've had several of their
people on on our show in interviews and
it's been very important for us it's
been very enlightening
but that's one of their central pillars
and ethos is to democratize the benefits
of artificial general intelligence
so if we truly want to do that we need
to access jeep we need to give
access of gpt-3 to people specifically
to even to the world
in a way that makes it so that it's
that it makes it so that people that
have great intention are able to use it
and provide value to the rest of
humanity
but people that have intentions that are
more malevolent
maybe have to go through a more
strenuous process
of maybe some sort of ethical or
spiritual or philosophical or moral
testing
in order to be able to use it the last
thing you want is to be generating
propaganda
for authoritarian dictatorships or or
violence or rape or any of these other
malevolences
so it's very very important to to
excuse me it's very important to
know how we are disseminating the
world's most cutting edge technologies
that's i mean that's pretty much it um i
i love you guys so much i really
appreciate everybody that checks out
what we put out here at simulation
obviously we are extremely polymathic as
you can tell we talk about
everything on this channel from science
to spirituality to metaphysics to
consciousness
but also to entrepreneurship to business
um to the best ways to disseminate the
cutting-edge technologies
and the fact that we can have a
conversation about
uh gpt-3 on one video and have a
conversation about
the tech congressional hearing and tick
tock on another video
and then on another video be talking
about the telos of
of reality and the logic of the infinite
and the recursive functionality of
of reality and how it is as though it is
one big
video game with these user interfaces
that we have
we are extremely polymathic and we hope
that it's bringing you tremendous
amounts of value as well
check out the rest of the content
subscribe if you haven't already give us
your comments and the thoughts below
become more polymathic yourselves
breadth
is the new depth the more breadth
you have look at look at the artificial
general intelligence look at gpt3
what is it famous for it's famous for
being task agnostic
it's famous for having a significant
amount of
breadth and so the more amount of
breadth that you have moving forward the
more you're able to
make these profound novel connections
across
disciplines and across fields the longer
you'll stay out of the crosshairs
of automation and the more relevant you
will be as a creative human
going into the future so
so embody the principle of being a
polymath of being a generalist at a
deeper level and share that with your
friends
and share that with your families your
communities in the world and create
build ideas and making execute execute
execute it's so important right now
understand the kingdom of god within
spirituality
and understand the nature of reality and
also understand how to bring forth ideas
into the world how to execute your gifts
and how to stay in touch with cutting
edge researches
like what's going on with gpt3 and
whatnot you
have to stay in touch with stuff like
this and you have to visualize as a
visionary
what it will be like for ourselves and
our children of the future
to be using these augmented reality
creative spaces and using natural
language and even just thought alone
to bring in these different coding
functions design
functions writing functions data
functions that we're seeking
and how that's going to maximize
creativity stay
relevant i love you very much thank you
for tuning in let me know your thoughts
and um let's build the more beautiful
world our hearts know is possible
inclusive stakeholding such a critical
pillar this big project
so love you guys very much and thank you
for tuning in
we'll talk to you more soon peace
you